[Musica]
[Applauso]
ismo berlino dove siete lombardino fai
lì sul tavolo successo qua merlino pop
corn e quindi si berlino berlino di
statuto prendere queste cose dalla
cucina fascismo vitale vitale di è
subito quello che è successo che cosa
stai facendo
stavo lavando i piatti guerra che cosa
ho trovato qua nel tavolino della tv
qualcuno ha mangiato questa notte è
pieno di pop corn snack merendine
qualcuno ho mangiato di nascosto
stanotte sei stato tu vero quando al
mattino che si sta mangiando tutti i pop
corn
sì ma marino non può aprire il cassetto
della cucina come ha fatto o forse hai
fatto togliere non ti ricordi mi sembra
che stai cercando una scusa per quello
che hai fatto tu e cioè andare in cucina
perchè affetto mangiare tutto di
nascosto e poi è pure lasciato le prove
qui e non ci stà aggiunto allora che
cos'è questa tracce di cioccolato dopo
jean dopo di cioccolato fatto apposta
cioccolato questo chimica quelle su
queste serate vedi sono i pop corn ei
cracker so io stavo mangiando il
cioccolato non queste cose
effettivamente lì non c'è il cioccolato
e ci credo tutto dove sono gli smoothies
ma sono spariti al piano di sopra e non
c'erano nel loro letto quindi devono
essere possono essere stati loro
uno di loro mangiare tutto questa notte
c'era scritto chiaramente di non dargli
mai da mangiare dopo mezzanotte
dobbiamo trovarli subito se hanno
mangiato dopo mezzanotte potrebbe essere
successo qualcosa di pericoloso dove
possiamo cerchiamo leaf nismo
verniciatura inizio qualcosa ma dove sei
di qua da una dietetico dentro si sono
nascosti dentro l'armadio no forse hanno
mangiato dopo mezzanotte e quindi sono
scomparsi magari era quello il pericolo
se mangiano dopo mezzanotte scompaiono
potrebbe essere non lo so mi è venuta
un'idea proverò ad attirare ghismo e di
sma con i pop corn isma dove siete
berlino aiutami acciaccati dove sono
dimmi dove sono tu probabilmente avrei
visto tutto vero ma sono interessato i
pop corn dimmi dove sono dati che c'è
berlino c'è qualcosa là dietro
eccolo kiss sto tremando
che cosa è successo che cosa ti hanno
fatto molto bene ma beh per fortuna
abbiamo ritrovato ghismo ma ora ci manca
l'altro blemi l'invito a ritrovare e se
ha mangiato dopo mezzanotte
potrebbe essere molto pericoloso
6 bis ma dove sei ma è fuori
ma dove sei this ma chi sono perché non
mi dici dove andrà
dimmi dove si nasconde solo
spaventatissima come te ricordando
l'armadio perché guarda l'armadio non mi
sembra che si stia niente dentro gaysmo
è tutto buio
continuiamo a cercare
[Musica]
forse l'unico modo è fare una trappola
ma mi sono dimenticata di dirvi mi
raccomando lasciate un bel mi piace
questo video entro 5 6 commi 5 4 3 2 1
via tempo scaduti e se non mi seguite
ancora suite abbiamo andate a seguirmi
il nome anita stories e se volete
seguitemi anche su tik tok il nome
sempre iniziatori secondo voi dove si
sarà nascosta che potevo continuare a
cercare sicuramente ai grammy piace
tantissimo mangiare quindi potrebbe
essere in cucina ci avevo pensato
potrebbe essere in cucina
andiamo a controllare subito e andiamo
in cucina maker essere acqua in cucina
che ma è sentito un rumore si guarda
l'armadio maggio si è aperto da solo
a meno che non ha offerto berlino
berlino ea partito un armadio
guardando marino è come se stesso
guardando qualcosa di invisibile
fantasma e guardando fatta stamattina
berlino hai aperto l'armadio come
possibile che sia aperta da solo non c'è
niente vistosissimo controlliamo
nell'armadio beh se ghismo appena uscita
dall armadio non sarà andata lontano
deve essere qua vicino
[Musica]
non c'è niente quando già vitale dove
sei
vitale marino gli sembri tu c'è qualcosa
dietro il divano
no non c'è niente ma mi sembra di aver
visto un orecchio che puntava da qua sta
succedendo qualcosa di strano forse
inutile continuare a cercare kiss ma se
vorrà tornerà prima o poi la vera fame
quindi tornerà per forza non è vero
ghismo gli small è un po strano che tipo
terrorizzato vabbè ma dov'è finito
evitargli tale forse ha salito su vitale
ferito sono spaventata ho preso la
scatola per fare la trappola che non
possiamo prendere possiamo fare una
sorta di trappola rifugio con la scatola
così possiamo riprenderlo e ri prendersi
cura di lui usato così magari sarà più
tranquillo
prepariamo la trappola ho un'idea si
vuole assolutamente del cibo
si sono d'accordo ci vuole assolutamente
del cibo
eccoci qua nella nostra cameretta come
possiamo fare per preparare questa
trappola
mettiamo il cibo dentro alla scatola ma
poi dobbiamo tenere la scatola aperta
potremo mettere un bastoncino ok
proviamo e speriamo che funzioni così
ancora la ruota dell'ultima challenge
challenge chi apre più regali vince in
cui abbiamo perso tantissimi calendari
dell'avvento se non l'avete vista andate
a vederla dopo questo video berlina
berlino da mangiare il cibo della
trappola da berlino non è per te è fermi
sma e per il grembo ho avuto un'idea per
evitare che gi smal gremlin rimanga
dentro la scatola magari noi non ce ne
accorgiamo metteremo questo pulsante
metteremo il cibo sopra così quando kiss
ma prendere il cibo schiaccerà il
pulsante suonerà l'allarme e potremmo
prenderlo subito
pensi di questa idea è un'ottima idea
passano subito dall'arma mettiamo
l'allarme qui speriamo che berlino non
mangia il cibo per i crediti
ho passato il ci compra molto
interessato berlino non è per te
pecchiamo anche il cibo sopra l'allarme
così quando lo prenderà suonerà e
ricopriamo il tutto copriamo il tutto
con questa semplice trappola nome lì non
ho questo non è premere video non è
andiamo portiamole mangiare di tutto
portiamo un berlino con noi che la
trappola è pronta ora andiamo via da
questa cameretta speriamo che funzioni
una trappola
voglio un metodo per distrarre berlino
questi croccantino forma di otto birdie
con la funzione almeno abbiamo testato
che la trappola un po da funziona è la
testata berlino anche se vogliono è
rimasto intrappolato per chi preferisce
circolare di nikolov e allora adesso la
risistemiamo dopo l'allarme è rimasto a
posto io li sistemiamo come un uovo così
e poi andiamo a chiudere il tutto così
perfetto sistemato tutto andiamo
speriamo solo che la trappola funzione
aspettano qui pazientemente
[Musica]
l'enorme devo andare a controllare chi
ma che cos'è quella cosa là sotto alla
scatola
[Musica]
provo ad alzare la scatola forse non è
una buona idea ma è stato troppo curiosa
isma berlino che faccio ho solo scatola
apro la scatola forse non è una buona
idea ma devo scoprire se c'è chi ma qua
dentro
sei tu
[Musica]